hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
and on the podcast in various episodes
and various guises
we've talked about morality right the
ideas of right and wrong and ethics and
so forth the philosophy
behind it it's a notoriously tricky
subject people don't agree
either on ethics what is right what is
wrong or
on meta ethics how we even decide what
is right and
what is wrong so the whole subject of
morality even though it's very important
we need to make decisions about what to
do
in our lives it's notoriously difficult
to reach consensus to find agreement on
what things are true it's not like
math where you say two plus two and
everyone says four
right everyone is in agreement about
that so turns out guess
what spoiler alert there are a lot more
similarities if you really dig in
between the ways that we can and should
and do
talk about morality and the ways that we
can and shouldn't do
talk about mathematics we have a feeling
that math is
enormously more rigorous and agreed upon
only because we don't think about it
that hard once you really approach the
philosophy of mathematics the
foundations of the subject
you realize people don't agree uh as
kurt gerdel famously proved there are
apparently true statements that you
can't actually prove as theorems
and so forth and you can actually draw
quite an elaborate analogy
between the philosophical status of
mathematics which is purportedly very
clear and certain and rigorous
and the philosophical status of morality
which is notoriously fuzzy
and that's exactly what is done by
today's podcast guest justin clark doan
who is a philosopher at columbia
university he doesn't say that morality
and mathematics are exactly analogous
but he does make the case that they are
more analogous than you might think
especially when it comes
to the extremely tricky question of what
is real are mathematical objects real
are moral beliefs real do they reflect
something objectively out there in the
world
and i've already made a mistake because
justin's whole point is that
being real is different from being
objective and we'll get into that and so
spoiler alert again um this is a this is
one of the hard ones
this is one of the podcasts and i say
this with great affection and it's all
completely intentional i'm glad it
turned out that way and you should
absolutely listen
but we get into the weeds because these
are really difficult issues
it's very easy to treat them
superficially
and not do them the justice that they
deserve because you know
two plus two equals four what else do
you need to know right killing babies is
wrong how hard can that be
well these are really hard neither math
nor morality are things that we fully
understood
and as we talk about at the very end of
the podcast the
fact that we can compare them at this
level of really really taking them
seriously foundationally
is something that is difficult to do in
our modern world where we're
hyper-specialized right
the people who are experts in the
philosophy of mathematics are not
experts in moral philosophy and vice
versa
so whatever you might think about the
substantive claims that justin and or i
might make over this podcast the project
is i think really crucially important
this this effort to really dig
in be careful be responsible be
intellectually honest
in more than one field at a time to
bring things together
and see what connections work what
connections don't work and so forth
helps us understand the world in new
ways that's what we're all about here at
the mindscape podcast so
let's go do
justin clarkdon welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks so much
thanks for having me so you've written a
book called morality and mathematics and
you know trying to think of a way into
the podcast i think the first question
to ask is what the hell like
what is the what is the punch line of
this why in the world are we motivated
to write a book or think about the
intersection of morality and mathematics
yeah the the the main reason is that um
superficially these areas can seem
totally different
um on the other hand um
under a microscope there's surprising
similarities
uh between the case for realism
about one or the other that is the case
for the existence of independent
facts of the matter um
and uh and it is a real
it turns out to be an important question
for naturalists people who think that
there is only basically the world
delivered by science
uh whether or not one can consistently
be
a mathematical realist and a moral
anti-realist so that's how it got
started so i mean i
guess the there are both
mathematical realist and anti-realists
and moral realists and anti-realists uh
but but maybe what you're saying is that
you know there there
might be the closest thing we have to a
consensus might be mathematical realism
and moral anti-realism yeah if they're
if you know i don't know the poll
numbers but
my guess is that certainly among
philosophers and scientists who
self-identify as naturalists they
they would if pressed say well look i
guess i gotta believe in
independent mathematical facts not just
because
it seems hard to believe that you know
if everyone were to die tomorrow it
would no longer be the case that two
plus two is four
but also because science is up to its
years in math and it's hard to even know
what it could mean to say something like
i believe in
you know our best physical theories but
i don't believe in math
as an independent um uh reality
so on the other hand science seems to
have no need for
independent moral facts uh at first
glance uh i suspect a naturalistically
inclined
philosopher scientist like yourself uh
would be inclined to say that come on
uh ethics uh is is something like a
matter of convention
there's obvious evolutionary reasons why
it might have benefited our ancestors to
establish norms of conduct that roughly
conform to the ones we've
arrived at and um and that's kind of all
there is to it but no need to postulate
in addition to these causal stories
about how we came to have the moral
beliefs we came to have
independent facts that we either get
right or don't as in the mathematical
case
good so okay that that makes sense so
it's not so much a
statement about like you say the poll
numbers overall but there is a specific
attitude that
certain of us might have scientific
naturalists etc
that that might go ten tend to go hand
in hand with moral realism and sorry
moral anti-realism but mathematical
realism
i i think so my prediction is we're
going to actually be talking more about
mathematics than morality in this
podcast because
uh everyone agrees that morality is is
tricky but
but i guess the the the insight that you
one of the insights you want to share is
that
the cases in each case for math and
morality are
more alike than you might think even
though they're not exactly alike is that
fair
right correct exactly that's right yeah
so let's talk about mathematical yeah
let's talk about mathematical realism uh
is that the same thing as platonism
should i i don't know what either one of
those means but
what do those mean and how should i
think about them yeah right uh
platonism has come to take on a bunch of
um connotations that are sort of
distracting in this context so
um i suspect that many people you know
who aren't familiar with the
the detailed literature will be inclined
to say look i think there's an
independent fact about whether the twin
primes conjecture is true
but um don't get me wrong i'm not some
kind of
crazy platonist you know i don't think
there's like platoplasm out there in
plato's heaven um look all i mean by
mathematical realism
is that mathematical statements of the
sort that you
encounter in an ordinary mathematics
class
whether it be you know number theory or
geometry or set theory
these have these have truth values
they're the kinds of things that can be
true or false
um and whether they're true is not up to
us
you know we don't get to decide whether
or not the twin primes conjecture is
true
uh we don't get to um uh
change our convention and make it false
we can of course mean different things
by the same symbols but that won't
change the truth value of the thing we
actually express
presently with the twin primes
conjecture sentence
so that's what i mean by mathematical
realism now
i should say that there it's not just a
coincidence that people often use the
word platonism
to describe such a position uh the
reason people use that word
is because it's very hard to see how
anything answering to the constraints i
just gave
could be anything other than what you
might call platonic objects
it doesn't seem like numbers for
instance are the kinds of things that
we're ever gonna you know observe
through a telescope
um that that you know building a bigger
particle accelerator is going to
discover so if there are such things as
infinitely many prime numbers um
uh and specifically twin prime numbers
then
um then evidently they'd be something
strange
uh from the standpoint of an ordinary
naturalist
why don't you remind us what the twin
primes conjecture is
it's just the claim that there are
infinitely many uh
not prime numbers p such that p plus two
is also prime
and have we proven this yet do we know
if it's true no we yeah an interesting
fact about it is that
people seem to be getting closer and
closer to proving it
in other words they're establishing that
there are infinitely many
prime numbers p such that p plus blah
blah blah is also prime
where blah blah blah gets lower and
lower but they have not proved that
there are infinitely many number
prime numbers p such that p plus two is
also prime
uh so um it's a claim that my general
senses
number theorists think is very likely to
be true
but it hasn't been proved right but we
for the examples that we're using here
i mean it's nice to pick an example
where we haven't proven it so that we
can sort of
sensibly talk about well what if it
weren't true uh
but the standing of all these claims is
just the same as if we talked about one
plus one equals two right uh
you mean the standing of the unproven
conjectures or the standing in general
of these kind of fancy mathematical
claims whether proven or not i just
meant that when you were talking about
uh the the truth there exists a truth
value
of a claim independent of human beings
etc we might as well just use one plus
one equals two as an example of this
right
sure sure yes there are some distracting
features
of the super rudimentary cases which is
one reason i prefer not to use them
i'll give you a simple example so um
so uh right you know ask
ask a philosopher for an example of a
kind of
um claim that you can tell just by
thinking
um that's also necessary that is it
couldn't have been otherwise and they're
likely to cite something like one plus
one is two
yeah it's a little tricky though because
the work the
the the sentence one plus one is two
um you know arguably goes
proxy a lot of the time in ordinary
language for a claim of pure logic
um so it arguably goes
proxy say for a claim like
if there's a book on the table and
there's a book on the
chair and no book on the table is a book
on the chair
then there are quote exactly two books
on the table or the chair
where exactly two there even though i'm
using the
expression two can actually be
defined without any reference to to
numbers
so this was you know a famous um
uh accomplishment of fragas to show that
that
sentences like that can actually just be
understood as claims of pure logic
where by pure logic for those who you
know
are familiar with this this language i
mean pure first order logic
um which is is kind of like the least
controversial
uh you know common core of logic that
every
philosophy student and analytic
philosophy gets introduced to for
instance
this is why talking to philosophers is
great you can really dig into one plus
one equals two in
a principled way which is fine um but
but still i mean i i want to keep that
simple example in mind because let me
put forward a naive point of view which
i think is
is the point of view but both that i
have and that you think i have
um which is that there's no such
thing as well it's not true that one
plus one equals two that's not the thing
that is true the thing that is true
is uh the statement one plus one equals
two
with certain conventional understanding
of what those symbols mean
and assuming certain axioms about number
theory
is true and if i had uh assumed
different axioms like if i were doing
addition modulo two so that one plus one
equals zero then it would not
be true and so there's a point of view
that says that
uh all mathematical truths are
are sort of conditional statements of
the form if you accept these axioms then
you get these theorems or something like
that
great yeah yeah so a couple things to
say about that so the first thing to say
is the thing i said a minute ago which
is that you gotta distinguish between
the truth of a sentence under some
interpretation or another
and the truth of what it expresses so
look
i could use um the sentence
um there are tall buildings to express
the claim that there are numbers
and under that interpretation if we
think there are numbers then we'll agree
that there are tall buildings before
going out and checking whether there are
any tall buildings
uh but obviously in ordinary language to
say that there are tall buildings has to
do with buildings not numbers so we're
not interested in the truth value of
that sentence under some interpretation
or another
we're interested in what it expresses
and one plus one is two
in ordinary language expresses that one
plus one is two
and so what we're interested in is the
status of that claim that's the first
point
okay but the second point more
importantly concerns
the prospects for um a kind of view
which is extremely tempting
and was um you know
quite popular at the turn of the 20th
century
and i don't want to make it sound like
it was all due to good ol
uh but the the the cartoon narrative is
the simplistic narrative is basically
after goodle's theorems this became
a whole lot less persuasive of a
position
here's the following position which i
take you to be sketching
which has a lot of appeal look i
distinguished a minute ago between
mathematics and logic
so i distinguished the claim that one
plus one is two which on a face value
reading says basically there are numbers
one and two and the one one bears the
plus relation to itself
and to two from the logical truth
that blah blah blah and i gave you that
logical truth
but why not now when we move to fancier
things like the twin prime conjecture
or something also have take those to be
surrogates
for logical truths now in this case we
can't take the surrogate logical truths
to be the same
sorts of logical truths there's no
logical truth
corresponding to the twin primes
conjecture of the sword i gave you for
one plus one is two
but there is the following kind of thing
that will work perfectly generally
whenever i say p for some mathematical
proposition
what i really mean is if the axioms are
true then p
right and that is if if if that
is if you can in fact prove p from the
axioms that's a logical truth
and now we're just in the business of
logic there's no special math you don't
need to believe
in whatever objects p refers to
okay there's a a number of issues to
deal with here
here's the first issue um if we think
the goal presumably is to be able to so
to
speak um uh do everything we wanted to
do previously and believe
all the sentences we wanted to believe
previously without really believing in
numbers and worrying about you know
objects outside of space-time how could
we know them and so forth
um so that means we want to be we don't
want to take a stand on whether the
axioms themselves
are satisfied that is whether they in
fact have
have a model whether or not there are in
fact
numbers such that you know you got zero
and you've got the
successor of a number whenever you've
got the number and you've got the
induction schema we don't want to worry
about whether or not there really is
such a
thing out there satisfying those we just
want to say those axioms whether
satisfied or not imply this other thing
yeah okay here's the here's the problem
if we take the claim
if the axioms then you know the twin
primes conjecture
to be what's called the material
conditional
basically just to claim if p then q
which is equivalent to either it's not
the case that p
or q well then if the axioms aren't
satisfied
that that whole thing comes out true no
matter what so it will be equally true
that the twin primes conjecture is true
on this reading and equally true that
it's false
if there's no numbers to satisfy the
axioms the deeper problem
if you replace the conditional with a
logical relation
is that um that it turns out
you know this is goodall's famous uh
second in completeness theorem to be it
that it's consistent to say false things
about
consistency so it's consistent to say
false things about what follows from the
axioms
so if piano arithmetic standard
arithmetic is consistent
then so is piano arithmetic conjoined
with a claim
that it proves an inconsistency because
if that weren't consistent then
arithmetic could prove its own
consistency if it were consistent and it
can't by goodall second and completeness
theorem
so this is why the these are some
reasons there's a bunch of reasons but
these are some of the reasons
why the very attractive thought that
lots and lots of people were
drawn to including russell hilbert and
others
before the 30s doesn't seem to stand up
to scrutiny
so here's a quiz when you're cooking and
seasoning your food should you add salt
first
or pepper first the answer is pepper
should come first
as you would know if you watched the
cooking basics what everyone should know
course from the great courses plus the
great courses plus is a streaming
service with hundreds of video and audio
lectures
on all sorts of different topics you can
learn how to speak a new language
how to play chess learn about the
history of world war
ii science topics of course i've done
topics for them
and with the great courses plus app you
can watch or listen on any device
so you can learn what you want when you
want to learn it wherever you are
in the world the cooking basics course
is taught by chef shawn kalberg
who has worked for world famous
restaurants like cafe des artiste in new
york
commander's palace in las vegas he
really knows what he's doing and
makes it all so easy right now mindscape
listeners get a 14-day free trial
with unlimited access so go to this
special url
thegreatcoursesplus.com mindscape
to take advantage of this all for now
that's t-h-e-great
courses p-l-u-s dot com slash mindscape
good so just uh this is exactly where my
head starts hurting and you know i love
this stuff i read girdle escherbach when
i was a kid
and i want to understand it better but
it's there's some there's some
aspect of it where i can i can get to
the point where
i am sure that i understand what's going
on and then the next day is completely
gone so i'm just going to keep trying
over and over again
uh so is the essence is the essence of
what you just said
the the idea at least post-girdle even
if it's not completely his fault but
that
you can't just associate truth with
theorem hood
uh that there's some some that that the
notions of being a theorem in an
axiomatic system and the notions of
being true
are different yeah that's that's um
that that would be a a kind of rough and
ready slogan
way of putting the upshot of the second
argument i gave
yeah yeah okay and uh there was
something
sneaked in there about first order logic
which implies that maybe under second
order logic it might be a different
situation
right okay so so so second order logic
um you know there's a famous debate
in philosophy about whether second order
logic deserves the title logic you'll
have to do the best you can
at explaining what first order logic is
and what second order logic is sorry oh
i'm sorry
right of course yeah yeah of course yes
so
first order logic um is
the logic that allows you to
talk about things and
predicate properties of them but not
talk about the properties you're
predicating of them roughly speaking
i say roughly because you could always
let properties be in the realm of things
you get to talk about
with the original variables that you're
ascribing predicates to
um but roughly speaking that's first
order logic
second order lot and the key terms here
for those of
you who want to pursue the matter more
the key terms are the
key term is quantifiers so in first
order logic you're allowed to quantify
over things but not quantify into
predicate position so you can say
there's an x such that x is tall
but you can't say there's an x such that
and there's an
x and there's an f such that x has f
um so where f is some property
like being tall in second order
logically you can do that sorry
you can quantify into predicate position
yeah i missed the distinction you just
drew there between
um saying that x is tall and saying that
x is
f and f means being tall okay so so in
first order logic you can say there's an
x and x is f
where uh you're not where where
you don't get to quantify into the
the the place of the predicate f so you
don't get to let that be a variable
so f is some constant predicate it
corresponds to
in the in in the technical like setup it
corresponds to a set of things
and and that sentence is true if there
if there is something in that set um in
second order logic you get to quantify
into
the place of that constant predicate f
so you get to say let's think of like a
small x and a big x just to make it
clear that we're talking about variables
you get to say there's a small x and
there's a big x
such that small such that big x
applies to small x but you don't get to
do that in first order logic that's the
idea
and does that mean it does actually make
sense roughly speaking and
uh or amazingly i should say uh and
is there something do i recollect
correctly that um
if we that number one second order logic
is not universally accepted
as a good way to go uh by logicians
we're philosophers and number two but if
we
help ourselves to it then we can
uh recover a notion of logical
uh of uh truth being close to theorem
hood or at least
um you know axioms picking out
structures in the world
yeah i mean the pro the the rough um so
okay right so as i was saying that you
know there's this like debate
about if famously quine said
a second order logic is just uh set
theory in sheep's clothing
and you can kind of get a sense of where
he would have been coming from from what
i just said about what second order
logic is
because you get to quantify over sets
basically now
there's some debate about whether that's
really the only way to read the second
order quantifiers
but on its face that's what you're doing
and it really looks like this is just
set theory
but here's the key point about why
people haven't
been impressed by appeal to second order
logic and trying to recover the idea
that
math is just logic in disguise the key
idea
is that second order logic is incomplete
and what i mean by that is you can come
up with
proof systems such that um
if if if the things uh if you can prove
the thing
then it's it's valid second order valid
but you can't come up with something
such that if it's second order valid you
can prove it
and so people feel like surely logic has
to correspond to provability i mean you
can use the word logic for some system
of truths
com some collection of truths but if it
doesn't correspond to things that could
in principle be proved
using some proof system that's a very
misleading way of putting the point
so that's why people have felt like
second order logic is not going to
vindicate
the original hopes both it seems to be
ontologically that is
um sort of to do with what exists it
seems to be committed
to basically just what math was
committed to
set you know sets um and objects
constructed out of them
but even if you don't want to worry
about ontology at the epistemological
level
it doesn't seem any easier to figure out
how we could be reliable detectors of
second order consequence
than it would be to tell how we could
just know the mathematical truths
understood at face value
okay i think i do understand that and
for the people listening out there
i think that's as weird as it's going to
get i really i kind of wanted to sort of
dig into
uh this particular area which is just as
recognized and and
difficult for me to understand you get
it out there on the table
um because it is just fascinating to me
and i it's a rabbit hole to go down but
but as you said before this was sort of
all this
was all this girdle and etc stuff and
truth being theorem hood or otherwise
yeah a set of ideas was one argument but
there's another argument about books on
chairs right and
i didn't want to let that completely
slip by because i think that this should
be graspable
to us all so do i understand correctly
that the
example of the books being on chairs was
somehow
meant to illustrate the idea that there
was uh a
logical truth about the idea of one plus
one equals two
yeah so um remember at the beginning i
started out with this example the twin
primes conjecture and then
and you pointed out rightly like but the
view is that the twin primes conjecture
has the same kind of status as two plus
two is four
so why don't we just use two plus two is
four and i said well that's a little
that can be a little confusing in this
debate because
um when you're talking about elementary
arithmetic truths like 2 plus 2 is 4 say
1 plus 1 is 2 because
already already that becomes complicated
when you try to
translate you know the the surrogate
logical truth into ordinary language but
um uh whereas one plus one is two say
there's a claim in the neighborhood that
arguably
in a given context is what we're really
trying to express
when we say that one plus one is two it
has nothing to do with numbers
and it's just a claim of pure logic that
everybody has to agree
is true um there's no surrogate claim
in the case of the twin primes
conjecture or even the claim
like you can't you know you can't tile a
certain floor a certain way because it
you know the number of tiles would be
prime or something
um i mean even you know what i'm saying
is
that i mean when you move beyond the
most rudimentary arithmetic cl
arithmetic claims
this simple translation scheme
get you know gives gives away and you no
longer can
can pull it off but the original point
was if you take something as simple as
one plus one is two
well and you ask what you know the
person on the street means by one plus
one is two
my guess is there's no clear answer to
that question
um they probably mean something like you
know
if there's a bike over there and there's
a bike over there
and no bike over there's a bike over
there then there's two bikes where two
bikes again is actually
shorthand for this complicated logical
expression
that doesn't involve reference to
numbers i see okay so this is this is an
argument for one plus one being
one plus one equals two not being the
paradigmatic example we should have
in mind uh because maybe yeah once you
want to get into the question
yeah if you if the if you want to have a
debate about whether to be a realist or
a platonist about
math it's i think it's distracting to
focus on the real rudimentary cases
because those i think are ambiguous in
natural language
between you know claims about numbers
and claims that everyone accepts whether
they're plainness or not
well maybe the other example that uh i
personally will always have in mind
and i want to see how it fits in here is
geometry and the parallel postulate
which is an obvious
sure example because back in the day
uh the postulate the two initially
parallel lines
stay at the same distance from each
other was
given by euclid as a postulate but
people thought oh come on we should be
able to prove that
and eventually we realized we couldn't
prove it
from the other axioms because in fact
you could replace it with different
axioms and get hyperbolic geometry or
imani in geometry or whatever
so given that given the the the fact
that in
geometry we have a clear case where
there are
alternate choices about what axioms to
pick that give rise to different truths
following from those axioms um how does
that fact
stand in relation to ideas about realism
about these claims like what is supposed
to be real what happens in the actual
world
or just some uh logical concatenation of
statements
good so um so
there's um a distinction
one has to accept between different
areas
of math at least prima facie and
you know stuart shapiro i think calls
the the kind of areas like geometry
uh algebraic areas you know just like it
would be
clearly misconceived to ask whether the
axiom of commutativity of groups is true
um period uh it would be misconceived to
ask whether the parallel postulate is
true period
on the other hand claims of
say arithmetic don't seem to have that
flavor
and you could think that we could just
sit tight there and and say okay they
don't seem to have that flavor
but you know on inspection the best
overall philosophy of math is going to
be one where it's all like geometry
everywhere but as i said a minute ago
that doesn't seem to be tenable
because arithmetic claims are
really or i should say claims about
consistency
are really arithmetic claims by
goodall's second and completeness
theorem
so in other words um suppose somebody
wants to say
here's a very let's put let's let's go
back to your original
view that you know sounded pretty good
something like
look you know there's just there's just
different axioms you can have and then
you can ask what follows from the axioms
like that's just logic
and there's no need to get into the
business of you know
speculative cosmology about numbers in
order to accept that
here's the problem claims about
consistency
oh if you want to take a stand on those
not being like the parallel postulate
so you can't just flip their truth value
by flipping you know the system you're
working in
um you you're taking a stand on
arithmetic not being like the parallel
postulate because those are arithmetic
claims
so just to repeat the example i gave if
standard arithmetic is consistent then
so is standard arithmetic conjoined with
a claim that says it's not
consistent it codes that claim um
so you've got two you've got two
theories then which are consistent if
standard arithmetic is one says
arith says the axioms and then it says
it's consistent
here's another theory standard
arithmetic the axioms plus the claim
by the way i'm not consistent those are
both consistent theories
so if the consistency claim is like the
parallel postulate then we can't even
take an objective stand on what's
consistent with what
and that seems like a little bit too
much to swallow it seems like
it's turtles all the way down at this
point and we've lost control of what we
were trying to say which was there's
facts about consistency and what follows
from what
but there's no additional facts about
like what axioms are
really true so so so the big picture is
right
realism is a question about sort of you
know
what's true independent of us but
there's this other dimension
of kind of the extent to which different
areas of math are like algebra
where you can just choose different
axioms and there's no real debate
and the the mathematical realism debate
is normally closely tied to a debate
about
how much our foundational theories are
theories in which you can carry out
metatherapic reasoning and talk about
things like consistency
the extent to which those are like
geometry
and the key theory there is set theory
and there are different places to draw
the line
uh and so for example and then i'll shut
up about this
in in the set theory case you know for
example
a very conservative view would be to say
that any arithmetically sound
set theory set theory is just the theory
of sex i know that's not this
uninformative sounding
claim but it's just the theory of
collections of things basically
and it turns out that you can take all
claims of math basically to be
to to to be short to be um
uh really just another way of saying
things about sets this is a surprising
fact because set theory has only one
non-logical predicate is a member of but
anyway
so here conservative view would be to
say that any arithmetically sound
set theory is as good as any other
and by arithmetically sound i mean a
theory that doesn't
prove a false arithmetic sentence but
many people say look once we're in the
business of taking a categorical stand
on the truth of the axioms
then why should we draw the line at
arithmetic shouldn't there be objective
facts about the axiom of choice
shouldn't there be objective facts about
what are called large cardinal axioms
and so forth
so there's a question of where you're
going to draw the line
once you grant that it can't all be like
geometry
so sorry that was a lot but the point is
there's two issues one is independent
truth the other is how much are
different branches of math like geometry
yeah no actually i'm going to i want to
sort of dwell on this a little bit
because
this is amazingly fantastic this is
clarifying things for me
that i have been confused about for
decades um
so let me see if i can re-state it in a
way and then you can tell me how close i
am to
having captured it um sure in my mind i
have this paradigmatic example of
geometry where there are different
choices about what axioms to start with
that get you different
theorems you can prove different true
statements you can make within those
axiomatic systems
and you're saying well you might be
seduced into thinking that
that is a model for all of mathematics
but here's a reason why it's not
because if you look at the example of
arithmetic
uh the the question of which axioms to
use in arithmetic
gets tied up with the question of the
consistency of those axioms in a way
that it's
not in the case of geometry and so our
willingness to just say
oh pick whatever axioms you want about
arithmetic
is lower than it is for the
corresponding geometrical axiom
yeah so so let me try to be a little
more explicit about that that's
correct um so uh it's not just that
um the uh truth of arithmetic claims
gets tied up with
the truth of claims about the
consistency of arithmetic claims it gets
tied up with the truth of consistency
claims period
right so for example the claim that like
set theory is consistent is really an
arithmetic claim
it's a claim that there is no
natural number that codes a proof of
zero equals one from the axioms of set
theory
and it turns out that if set theory is
consistent
it's also consistent to say that there
is a number
that codes the claim of zero equals one
from the axioms of set theory
and what's going on there is that a
model of that overall
theory is wrong basically about what
counts as a natural number
from our perspective if we want to be
objectivists you might say about this
and not think it's like geometry
what we what we're gonna say is what's
going on is that model thinks that a
number
that is not finitely many steps away
from zero
is actually finitely many steps away
from zero and that's the number
witnessing the
proof of zero equals one so so that
so what you said is basically right i
just want to be clear that it's a very
general point not something about just
arithmetic it's that here's here's the
here's a slogan form of it
if you want to take a stand on the if
if you want to take a stand on the
consistency of theories
then you're already taking a stand on
arithmetic
there's no way of of saying i accept
that there's a fact of the matter about
which theories are consistent in general
while saying
uh but let let a thousand flowers bloom
any
set of axioms is as good as any other
because some of those axioms are going
to disagree about consistency
right right hiring people for your
business
is one of those things you do not want
to mess up you need to hire great people
if you want to take your entire business
to the next level with the stakes this
high there's only one choice
indeed indeed.com is the hiring site
that helps you find
quality candidates with indeed instant
match
indeed searches through millions of
resumes in their database to show you
the great candidates instantly
so you can do the part you really need
faster meeting and hiring great people
according to indeed data candidates
invited to apply through instant match
are three times more likely to apply for
your job
than those who only see it in search and
with indeed there are no long-term
contracts you can pause your account at
any time and only pay for what you need
so if you want your quality shortlist
fast you need indeed
right now our listeners get a free 75
credit to upgrade your job post
at indeed.com mindscape this is indeed's
best offer anywhere
free 75 credit at indeed.com
mindscape offer valid through march 31
terms and conditions apply
and the connection it seems to be coming
right up to this
connection to realism so you're saying
that
exactly because arithmetic has this uh
set of implications for consistency
we want to think that a certain
viewpoint i don't know if it's right to
say a certain set of axioms but at least
a certain version of
arithmetic is the right one the real one
the true one
is that if i gone too far now that is
certainly
that is certainly the um you know
initially appealing view i mean uh
so look there's a bunch of issues in the
background that
once again kind of like with the two
plus two is four versus twin primes case
that
that
can can be confusing so maybe i should
just distinguish
um look there's well-known debates about
which
logic is correct so evidently those
debates
those debates bear on what's consistent
but but i want to be clear that this is
an orthogonal issue
this is basically a debate about what
whether there's an objective fact about
what's finite
so so a way to put it is if you were to
deny
that um there is an objective fact about
um you know the claim that codes
uh the consistency of piano arithmetic
if you wanted to deny that what you'd be
denying is that there's an objective
fact
um of whether something's a proof in a
system of logic where we're we're
allowed to look at different logics
so so so one debate is do we know what
we mean by finite and what i'm saying at
the moment is it sure seems like we
better
another debate is once we think we know
what we mean by finite what's the right
logic
so so so that's a complication
back to the issue of realism realism
is is once again sort of like an
independent parameter
in the sense that one could in principle
be a realist think there are independent
facts
to which our mathematical theories
answer but
so to speak it is all like geometry
and in fact one could even be a realist
and think that
logic the question of what logic is
correct is like geometry
one could have this view so for example
um
you know there's not many people who are
willing to go in print
uh with with the view all that that you
know
rides this train to the last station as
i've been discussing but there's a
couple
and so for example you know joel david
hampkins
um in his work on the multiverse has at
least flirted with the idea
that even questions of consistency in a
logic
um are like the parallel postulate
question right now
most people feel like i've totally lost
my bearings and now there's not even
going to be a fact about what's in the
multiverse
because it's going to depend on sort of
from what perspective
in it you take but but um
but i i don't want to make it sound like
that's all the way off
limits there are you know respectable
and interesting
defenses of that position most people
feel like you got to draw the line
before that but
that view and this is the last thing
i'll say on this is a realist view
so so so you know um
joel describes his view as a platonist
multiverse view he thinks that you know
it's
it's almost like platonism on steroids
because where you might have thought
there's just the set theoretic universe
and the natural numbers and so forth he
thinks that there's
so to speak a set theoretic universe for
any set of axioms you might
want to entertain including ones that
disagree with us about consistency
right good i think i got that i think i
got that
um and i i i i'm always attracted to the
sort of maximally pluralist crazy view
but um
uh maybe that's right right maybe
there's good reasons against it but so
let me let me sort of bring it back down
to earth a little bit by kind of um
retweeting because i think i think
you've already answered this but i'm
just going to ask you to answer once
again now that we
know we've laid out so much groundwork
um here is a view
that i might have had um
and and you don't you're not under the
obligation to give me everyone's
response to it just tell me what you
think is
the best response to it um the view is
there's a world
there's a real world there's reality um
and i'm going to be
human for those of us who are listen to
this who've also we
i talked with ned hall a while ago about
humanism about laws
so um there's not we don't think of the
laws of physics as
things that have separate existence we
just think of them as descriptions
of the world okay so i'm a reality
realist i think that the real physical
world is real and that exists
um but i don't want to be and again this
is just the straw man position that
we're going to squash once and for all i
don't want to be a mathematical realist
i want to think i i just want to say
that all that exists
is the world and mathematical language
can be a convenient way for we
subsets of the world to talk about the
world but that doesn't
imply that it has any uh separate real
existence
so um you know once and for all squash
that
okay well look i i won't i won't claim
to do that but um but here's here's a
few
thoughts to have okay so the initial
thought is
is a familiar thought from this
literature
um for people interested it's called uh
the literature on the indispensability
argument so
so just to um a little background
you know wd equine uh famously
um wanted to be a what's called a
nominalist
about all abstract objects all things
like
numbers and universals and things that
wouldn't be part of the ordinary
physical world that
you know sean you're like
you know you uh you have a uh admirable
belief in
uh uh he he um he wanted to be a realist
about that and kind of
that's it and um and so he tried
to figure out how to formulate
all of basically our physical theories
in a way that doesn't make any reference
to abstract objects he figured look if
if this is just a language just a
shorthand way
of saying something strictly about the
physical world
then i should be able to say it in
principle when the chips are down
even if for you know purposes of uh
ordinary calculation no one should waste
their time
pulling off the translation and and you
know he and goodman wrote this famous
paper
steps towards the constructive
nominalism where they started
uh that project well long story short
kwine came to think this is not gonna
happen this is not gonna be able to work
and he became
a quote reluctant platonist so so
so coin's view about math is is sort of
a
um it's sort of an awkward component to
his overall empiricism he was a kind of
you know radical empiricist he didn't
accept all sorts of stuff
that um ordinary philosophers who are
quite empiricist-minded philosophers uh
do but he felt like i gotta at the end
of the day
accept math and be a platonist about it
because
i want to accept science and what in the
hell could it mean to say i accept the
standard model of particle physics and i
don't believe in math you know i mean
like what does that mean
so um that's the first point the second
point
is even if you thought that either you
could in principle pull this project off
and by the way people continue to try so
archery field famously
um you know inaugurated a kind of new
approach to it
um uh even if you thought you could pull
this project off
it's hard to see what you're really
gaining and here's
here's a short version of why um
everybody needs to be able to talk about
consistency
i just said a minute ago the talk of
consistency can be understood as just an
arithmetic claim
now people like hartree field
or people who want to make no reference
to mathematical entities
still need to talk about consistency
because they want to be able to say
things like their physical theory that
makes no reference to mathematical
entities is consistent
so what they do is they introduce this
primitive bit of what's called
modal ideology modality is just the
theory of possibility and necessity and
you can think of consistency as a kind
of possibility claim logical possibility
so something's consistent if it's
logically possible
and what they do is they they they
introduce this is a primitive
bit of kind of terminology in the formal
framework
and they take a stand of course on
what's consistent with what and they
and they claim that you know physics is
consistent but that doesn't talk about
numbers
my feeling is what is gained by that
so okay let's suppose you could pull
this off let's suppose that you could do
away with any talk of numbers and in
fact there's cheap ways of doing this
too which i won't go into right now
unless you want me to but there's cheap
ways of avoiding any reference to
mathematical entities too
but you just trade all that ontology
that is all that reference to
mathematical entities
for beefed up what coin called ideology
that is
basically operators in your basic
language
and where the original question is how
in the world am i supposed to know these
arithmetic facts about
things that i can't bump into or do
experiments on
you're trading that for a claim of the
form
uh you know diamond that's the symbol
used
and then follow that with the claim p
that you want to claim is consistent
where exactly the same epistemological
problems arise how am i supposed to know
that there's no experiment
there's no um you know there's no
observation
it's it has exactly the same kind of
epistemological status
as the status of the arithmetic claim
that we wanted to do away with
so the the big picture is on the one
hand it's very hard to see how to pull
off the project
because it's hard to see what you could
even mean to say that you believe and
say
you know i mean you've written a bunch
on like quantum field theory and things
like this and
general relativity it's hard to see what
you could even mean by saying you ex you
really believe all that but don't get me
wrong i don't i'm not a mathematical
realist
um but the second thing is even if you
could make sense of what you mean
uh you're gonna be committed to claims
which seem just as good as arithmetic
claims from the standpoint of
epistemology
and so i don't really see what's gained
from the standpoint of
the problems that have traditionally
motivated the desire to get rid of
mathematical entities namely how could
we know about these things outside of
space and time
surely we just believe in the physical
world and
and what work you know and what we can
know about via observation and
experiment
right so i don't know if that
permanently dissolved review but there
you go
only temporarily i'm afraid nothing
nothing permanent in this world uh but
at least temporarily
i i get the thrust of it um
but i also so that's sort of the straw
man
um anti-realist position but but let's
let's also
squash the straw man realist position
that says
you know there is i forget what you call
it platoplasm uh that there are
triangles in the sky
and we're all participating in
triangleness or something like that like
that's not necessarily what is meant by
mathematical realism it's not the kind
you need to talk about the standard
model of particle physics it's more
something about the mind independent
truth
of mathematical statements yeah yeah
that's exactly right i mean look
the the um the triangle in the sky stuff
presumably
um presumably yeah was was never really
a part of
the the realism that anyone advocated
that i know of after plato plato with
his forms and
and the things in the world that that
mimic them but
um but as i said at the beginning
platonism
as the view that there are abstract
objects
um that view does seem to be a little
hard to deny if you're a mathematical
realist because
let's just understand mathematical
realism is the following view
mathematical claims are the sort you
encounter in say number theory class
they're true or false independent of us
independent of our conventions again of
course we could mean different things by
the same sentences that's irrelevant
that's like saying that you could meet
you know
that that that banks might not be
monetary institutions because you could
mean
instead that there are you know land
masses
on a body of water that doesn't mean
anything about banks it means something
about the word bank
um right so um so
uh the the idea then would be that you
know
we accept these claims as true
independent of us
but what what are they talking about i
mean they're talking about
numbers and you know metric tensors and
whatever
and um so so on an ordinary
understanding of how
truth works and by truth i don't mean
something heavy duty like capital t
i mean like basically just what it takes
for a sentence to get it right
like a very minimal idea stemming from
tarsky
there's gotta if if the sentence there
are prime numbers greater than a million
is true
in just this very minimal sense of truth
then there's gotta be something
witnessing that
and it's gotta be a prime number yeah
and what would that be
so so i don't want to make it sound like
the
cartoon uh the if the cartoon view is
supposed to be
just the view that there really are
abstract objects and that's part of
belief in realism
i don't want to make it sound like that
view silly because it actually is pretty
hard to see how you can be a realist and
not think that
um but of course that view is not the
view that there's triangles in the sky
right yeah well but i guess you know
where what part of the problem here is
that we are using natural language words
like
exist or to be or are real
uh to to apply to tables and chairs
and quantum wave functions and triangles
and maybe is it has anyone i'm sure
someone has but uh is it worth
exploring the project of you know
putting subscripts on these different
meanings of the word real when we're
talking about these different realms
yeah sure so so look there there is a um
a lively debate about whether
um existence might in some sense
be relative um the the
the the the literature that
is kind of most developed on this and
most
um taken most seriously today is the
literature on what's called quantifier
variants
but here's the standard kind of
um without getting into the
technicalities of why
those arguments you know might not be
compelling
here's the standard alternative point of
view for example was quine's
look something either exists or it
doesn't when you what you really mean to
be saying when you say something like
numbers exist in a different sense than
than electrons
is just that they're different
you know numbers don't exist in sp
numbers aren't in space and time
they um you know they they don't have
energy
um you know blah blah blah but um
but uh the notion of existence is just
supposed to be the thinnest
possible notion it's supposed to be
basically there are truths about the
thing
right and um you know you you could
introduce
by stipulation subscripts to different
uses of the word exists to mean
so for example there would be no
objection from this point of view to say
whenever i say exist sub two what i mean
is it exists and it's abstract
yeah okay fine but but then all we're
just saying is
yeah it's just something that we can now
say in the original language using the
one and
once and for all exists so so i mean
you know this i if there's anything like
a consensus on this the view is like
look we can introduce by stipulation a
thinnest possible notion of
exist it's the sense in which if there's
a god it exists it's the sense in which
there are numbers they exist
their wave functions they exist if
there's you know space-time points they
exist
if there's moral values they exist it's
the same sense of course all these
things are wildly different things
and so they they all exist or not
but they'll have different properties um
but it's just kind of like
a it's just kind of like confusing the
debate to start using that one word
which
you know is the one of the few things we
thought we had a grip on in philosophy
in different ways that's the kind of
standard
alternative view i got it yeah i think
actually that's uh
less immediately compelling to me than
the other things you said but i
but i will i do appreciate the force
of the argument but yeah but you know it
so you've just
uh made a reasonable case against
uh slicing the concept of reality too
thinly but one of the moves you do make
in the book
is distinguishing the concepts of
reality versus being objective
right i mean this is a major emphasis of
what you're trying to say so
naively you might mix up those two
things what do you mean by being
objective uh if other than being real
yeah
yeah good so i mean this is exactly
where your example of the parallel
postulate
it comes in real handy so by being real
or realism i just mean that there's an
independent fact about the thing
by being objective i mean that to us to
a question from the area only one answer
can be right and the parallel postulate
gives us an interesting case to think
about in teasing these
concepts apart because suppose you're
like a platonist like you know the
the the you know cartoon platonist is
kurt goodall
and you know you might ask what did kurt
goodall think about geometry not set
theory or arithmetic geometry i mean
as far as i know at least and it would
be shocking to learn
he didn't think that there was like one
true geometry as a matter of pure
mathematics of course there's one true
physical geometry
most people would assume but um but
you know it's not like he thought that
sadly hyperbolic space
doesn't you know it wasn't allowed into
plato's heaven but euclidean space was
um okay so there's some sense in which
there's no objective fact of the matter
as to whether the parallel postulate
understood as a question of pure
mathematics is right or wrong you can
sort of have it either way
if you want it true well then i've got
euclidean geometry for you if you want
it false
i hereby give you hyperbolic geometry
there's no real objective matter of fact
but of course
once we fix the meanings of the terms if
we're like good ol and we're realists
there's a perfectly independent fact
it's not like we get to make up
the facts about hyper hyperbolic space
or euclidean space
so so what you might think of is like
questions of
objectivity is kind of like a matter of
uniqueness it's a matter of like the
richness of the reality are there lots
of different realities
kind of all answering to this discourse
or is there like a unique reality
whereas realism is just the question of
what is the nature of the reality is it
mind-dependent
is it convention dependent uh or is it
totally independent of us
in every interesting sense that's the
idea okay now that actually does make
sense that sounds like a useful
distinction and maybe one of the uses
is when we finally get to compare all of
our
newfound mathematical uh sophistication
to morality
right now given that we now understand
math morality should be easy right
so what are the what are the options on
the table when it comes to moral
philosophy or
are even are we even going to worry
about uh moral realist positions are we
just going to say you know like we're
good naturalists we're not moral
realists we just want to compare it to
math
um okay so so um you know the
the the point of the the first chunk of
the book
until the last chapter is to say that on
when it comes to the question of realism
uh
moral realism is on every bit as good
footing
as mathematical realism as as surprising
as that
would sound so for example all the
obvious analogies i argue
don't hold up to scrutiny like that
well we settle things in math once and
for all with proof
whereas in ethics just people argue
endlessly
um or in in math you know
our theories get applied to the physical
world whereas there's no analog
in the moral case or you know in ethics
we can explain why we have the moral
beliefs we have
without appealing to their truth via say
evolution
or something whereas there's no analog
in the mathematical case
and so on and so forth so you know we
haven't talked about that stuff but just
to
let you know i go through all that stuff
and the argument is supposed to be
on none of those you know on
when it comes to none of those issues is
there actually a deep
disanalogy as surprising as that sounds
okay
we then go get to the issue of
objectivity
and the position that i advocate and you
know this is
controversial of course about math is
um the one i sort of mentioned earlier
when i said a conservative you would be
that is
it's it's the furthest view in the
direction
of it's all like geometry that you can
go without
losing a grip on you know um
what you mean because of this stuff we
talked about with goodall and
consistency and how that's tied up with
arithmetic
so the final view about math is realism
it we don't get to make up the
mathematical facts you know i think that
um that
one simple reason to think that is we
don't get to make up the physical facts
and the physical facts are up to their
ears in mathematical facts so
yeah so there's there's no clear way to
be a physical realist
a naturalist and not a mathematical
realist on the other hand
what the debates that have occupied most
people in the foundations of math
for most of the last hundred years
debates about axioms like the axiom of
choice
debates about axioms like uh
extensions of zfc like um
what are called large cardinal axis
strong axioms of infinity
those debates i think are all like a
debate over the parallel postulate would
be
if we were so misguided as to have one
understood as a pure mathematical debate
yeah so math i think in a slogan
is as non-objective as you can be
without getting into the problems i
mentioned at the beginning
um but it's perfectly real and
independent of us and we don't get to
make up the truth
okay but here's the trouble in the moral
case
moral realism i think as i said i you
know the the argument of the book is
that it's on as good footing as
mathematical realism and actually
there's a case to be made that i won't
go into right now
that it's on better footing i mean it's
that once you really get clear about
what moral realism is
is saying it's kind of hard to see how
it could fail to be true
here's one simple idea for for for why
that might be so
math has its own special subject matter
or in the lingo of philosophy its own
ontology
but morality actually doesn't it's about
things like you and me
and societies and so forth and all it
does is predicate new properties of them
but it turns out to be an enormously
difficult question to be clear
about what it means to say there are new
properties that is to say
it turns out to be an enormously
difficult question to be clear about
what it would mean to be
say a realist about some properties over
and above some other properties
unless you want to be what's called a
platonist about properties
which nobody does in these debates
because that's a different issue
and one that certainly a naturalist
shouldn't be inclined towards
so that's kind of like just a you know a
sketch of a reason to think that it's
not just that
moral realism is on as good footing as
mathematical realism and
it the case is stronger actually it's
hard to see how not to be a moral
realist you might say
okay but here's the issue whereas in the
mathematical case
with the exception of these arithmetic
sentences that i
think that you know we really can't be
pluralists about we really can't say
it's like geometry
because they're so tied up with lot
metalogic um
in the ethical case we don't seem to
have the
option of that kind of pluralism because
ethics unlike math or
physics or geography is supposed to tell
us what to do
if i'm wondering to use a you know trite
case from the utilitarianism versus
deontology debate
whether to kill the one to save the five
i can't say well it's morally good
sub one to kill the one to save the five
it's morally
too bad sub two bad to kill the one to
save the five and that's all there is to
it because now i gotta figure out
whether to kill
whether to do what's morally good sub
one or morally good sub two
the question gets delayed and what i
think this
shows is that though moral realism
in this strict sense is on just as good
footing as mathematical realism and
in a in in effect it it comes cheaply
and so in fact does what you might call
moral pluralism the idea that moral
truths aren't even unique
it's like geometry and ethics also but
what it shows is that the final question
before
action the question that we are asking
ourselves when we ask ourselves what to
do
the deliberative question is not a
question of fact
even if there were moral facts it's not
that question
so so just to be be clear then i'll shut
up about this um
hume famously said you can't derive an
op from an is that
is pretty uncontroversial you can't you
know learn that something's natural
and then you know infer from it that
therefore it's good or something
i'm saying that you can't even derive a
what to do
from a question of odd you can't even
derive a okay so this is the right thing
to do or this is the good thing to do
that won't even settle the question of
what to do
as a question of action so questions of
action
are objective but they're totally not
real they're the things that remain when
the facts are settled
whereas um you know uh mathematical
facts are totally real but totally not
objective or
as not objective as you can be without
getting into the quicksand of the good
old stuff
i guess i'm a little bit confused
because some of the things you said
seem to take implicitly to break the
question of uh
whether there is objective moral
statements i mean if we just believe to
again be super strong manny about it
that what we
call morality is just a gussied-up
version of people's preferences
um you know i prefer that you not do
that i prefer that you do do that etc
then this right then i don't see how it
how the claim that morality if i
if how can i then be forced into
believing in more realism
uh even if i bought into your claims
about mathematical realism
okay good so i mean so there's a there's
uh there's a verbal in the pejorative
sense
issue going on here that we
that we should clear up and that is one
question is just
what is the right natural language
semantics of moral claims
sure and my feeling is that there's
probably no determinant natural language
of moral claims people probably mean
lots of different things
and once you start reading a lot of
philosophy your meaning probably changes
and so forth
so look at the turn of the 20th century
as
as you well know um there was a project
of trying to show that all we mean
in saying that something is good or bad
is something like
boo that thing or yay or sorry yay that
thing or boo that thing
we're not saying something that can even
be true or false because boo and yay
can't be true or false we're doing
something more like venting emotion like
you do at a football game
yeah um so certainly in that case
there's no moral facts
there's not even relative facts we're
not even in the business of stating
any kind of fact um that is a question
of natural language semantics that's a
question of what people are actually
doing
when they utter some sounds there's
another question of set aside natural
language semantics i hereby
stipulatively introduce some language
that will concern how we ought to live
our lives
independent of what anybody thinks and
what i'm saying is belief in those
things whether or not that's what
ordinary people are talking about
that's on as good footing as belief in
the belief in say numbers
but that's not what settles practical
questions
what settles practical questions is more
like the stuff you believe in
it's more like stuff like questions that
don't have truth values
so when i ask myself my myself the
question of what to do
i'm not asking myself the question of
what i ought to do
because questions of what i ought to do
if the argument is sound don't settle
questions of what to do because i ought
say utilitarian kill the one to save the
five
i uh don't day ontological not and now
the question is just
whether to do what i ought utilitarian
or other ontological to do
and that can't be a question of whether
i ought in some other sense do it on
pain of regress
so so you might be right about natural
language semantics but i don't see how
that settles the metaphysics which is
what seems to me to be the important
point nope sorry this lost me completely
um
oh sorry okay i go along no i mean i
really really want to get this
so i completely buy that there is
something called
what i ought to do under utilitarianism
there's something else called what i
ought to do
deontologically or probably many
different subversions of all those
things
um yes yes but and that but then i don't
see any extra thing from that i mean so
so then sometimes what you're saying
seems to presume that there is some
just capital ought thing i ought to do
uh
are you saying that are you denying that
what i'm saying is
even if there were such a thing and the
the key question is what you could mean
by that but even if there were such a
thing
it wouldn't settle what to do where that
what to do is the question of action
so so here here's the point let's go
back to the mathematical case
where we're not dealing with arithmetic
the position of the book and i think
you're sympathetic to this but let me
know if not
is that the question of whether every
non-empty set has a choice function
that's just the action of choice is like
the parallel postulate question we don't
need to take a stand we can say
every set sub 1 has a choice function
but some sets sub 2 don't
and that's all there is to it everybody
can have their own set theoretic
universe and go home happy
so long as we stick to arithmetic
objective
arithmetic objectivity okay question
could you hold that our ethics is like
that could you hold that the question of
whether we ought to kill the one to save
the five is like the parallel postulate
question
i don't think so you could hold it the
question of whether we ought to
realistically construed is
but that would just show that questions
of what we ought to do realistically
construed don't settle questions of what
to do
that is questions of you know action
questions of
that we're deliberating over because
whereas in the
set theoretic case you can sort of have
all the truths laid out before
you and you can help yourself to one or
another depending on your interests and
aims
in the ethical case we're supposed to
appeal to ethics to figure out whether
to kill the one to save
the five and we can only do one or the
other we can't have it both ways
we have to take a stand in ethics or an
action i should say
in a way that we don't have to take a
stand in math
so um what i'm saying back to your
question is
um even if the notion of capital ought
made sense and i don't know what you you
mean by that beyond just saying that
there are some independent truths about
what you ought to do which i'm fine with
even if that notion made sense it
wouldn't actually do what you'd want it
to do because it wouldn't tell you what
to do
well is there a distinction between so i
i
i think you're drawing a distinction but
i'm not sure i've heard it drawn before
and
if so i want to separate out the
questions uh between
sort of the judgment aspect of morality
just attaching the label of rightness
and wrongness to different perspective
actions
versus the action question how to
operationalize that
and do something in response to it are
these are you saying that these are just
two separate questions
um well those are definitely separate
questions what's a little
less clear is whether
there's a question in between so here's
here's three different questions
i think good one question is what ought
i do
understood is like a factual question
about ethics
another question is what i will do
understood as a descriptive question
about kind of like predictive psychology
yeah
i'm claiming there's a question in
between which is what to do
and sometimes sadly it might be that i
deem
that you know the thing to do roughly
speaking
is x but i'm weak willed so i don't do
it
so the answer to the question of what i
will do is that i won't do x
the question of what i ought to do we
could have it be either you ought to do
x or you ought not
but the intermediate question of what to
do
is x do x you might think of the answer
to the question of what to do
as an imperative rather than a factual
claim so
when i ask myself i can ask myself the
factual claim you know whether to
whether i ought to kill the one to save
the five and i ought utilitarian and i
ought not deontological and you know as
you say there's virtue ethics and a
million other
subscripts we could add and these are
just all laid out before me like the
different mathematical universes
the different set theoretic universes
now there's the question of which to
use that can't be the question which i
ought to use
where ought is subscripted to one of
these objects in the moral plural verse
on pain of triviality so there's the
question of which to use
now the answer that's gonna get is not a
question you ought to use
this or that because ought is going to
be subscripted to one of these odds in
the moral pluriverse
it's going to be something like use that
one where that can't be true or false
and it doesn't pretend to describe
anything
but of course it could be that use that
one
even though i don't end up using that
one because i'm weak willed
well but okay um good i'm coming closer
i am actually inching closer that's it's
slow it's gradual it's painful but i'm
getting closer to the goal here
so good the question of what ought to do
is kind of like the geometry question we
could choose different systems right and
get different
notion notions of audit in there um but
in the case
uh but i don't want to do this but i
could imagine
someone saying that uh there's an
analogy between uh the mathematics of
geometry where you have many different
axiom choices and many different
uh possible consequences thereof and
the real single physical world where
there's an actual one that is realized
in nature
and that's analogized to the many
different ethical systems that have
different notions of what
and the real one the one that is
actually the true one right
and again i don't want to be that person
but i can there are people like that
right
yeah so the million-dollar question is
what they could possibly mean
and so here's what they if you want to
get into the
um nitty gritty of the debate here's
what they actually
say they mean so um okay so
uh famously nelson goodman
in the 50s pointed out that
um uh it's um so nelson goodman in the
50s pointed out that
um you know not just
you can't induct on any predicate some
predicates are what he called
projectable and others aren't this was a
kind of radicalization of hume's point
that you can know that all f's to date
have been g
but not be certain that the next f will
be g there's no deductive argument from
that fact to the next step
goodman's point is there's not even an
inductive argument
from the claim that all f's to date have
been g to the next step will be g
for lots of choices of g the the choice
of g needs to be what's called
projectable now what does that mean is
there any informative gloss
on the good predicates and the bad
predicates and
one view that came to be adopted is that
the good predicates are what
um you might call like natural kinds
there they carve nature at the joints
they're they're not the gerrymandered
things and
this view um came to be adopted in lots
of areas besides natural science
and one area where it can be adopted is
ethics you might say yeah there's the
moral pluriverse
but one of these moral-like properties
is like the natural kind in the moral
plural verse
it's the analog to the right way of
carving up the physical universe or
something
and this is in fact exactly what you
know
people like david enoch um people like
tristan mcpherson
other realists say about this pluralist
issue it's hard to deny that there is a
property of maximizing utility i mean
if there's properties at all the the
problem is that if utilitarianism is
false that's not the natural kind so to
speak that's not the
that's not the one that glows okay but
here's the problem
and this this problem in you know one
form or another was pointed out by
scupta in uh in in in the case of
natural science
um the problem is that either the claim
that these properties are natural kinds
is itself
a normative claim a claim that carries
with it
information about that you ought to use
it or not
if it's not then it's just like the
original
hume case where you learn that it's
natural but who cares
that is it's like learning that it's
brown it's neither here nor there from
the standpoint of practical deliberation
so maybe it's the moral natural kind i'm
wondering which one to use and it
doesn't pretend to speak to that
okay if it is a claim
with normative import telling us which
to you
which we ought to use then the problem
of pluralism rearrises at the level of
natural kinds
so we ought sub 1 use utilitarian
art use deontological odd or another way
to put it is
it's a natural kind someone that
utilitarian
sorry i should say utilitarian art is a
natural kind someone
deontological law is a natural kind sub
two and so on and so forth
so the problem just rearizes at the meta
level it realizes at the level of what
counts as
what you're calling the one true moral
universe
and um so it seems to me that that
doesn't actually get off the ground
if the problem is a problem to start
with it's equally a problem with the
alleged solution
yeah so this is i i actually am making
progress i think so i'm almost hesitant
to
um say what i think you've said because
i'm sure i'm not going to get 100 right
but
let me let me put it this way i was
initially uh confused
by on the one hand you know you give a
good
sales pitch for mathematical realism on
the other hand
you say that moral realism is on um
a similar ground and uh i didn't see
that but i think
i think the missing part was uh it's a
thin
kind of mathematical realism in some
sense uh or rather i mean maybe it's
just mathematical realism but the
the analogous thing in the moral domain
is a thin kind of moral realism compared
to what some people
might want you're you're saying that
you're a moral real
you're you're defending moral realism in
the same sense as mathematical realism
and of course in the mathematics
uh universe we could have different
axioms for geometry but then
there's some reality to the relations or
to the truths or
or whatever um so even though you say
you're a moral realist or
i don't know i don't want to say you're
morally realist but you're defending
moral realism as analogous to
mathematical realism
it does not go so far as to tell us what
to do
it does not give us unique imperatives
to act exactly is that right okay
exactly and here's here here's here's i
just want to be clear about the strength
of the claim the claim is not just that
like here's a position one could have
moral realism plus the claim that it
doesn't tell us what to do
what i'm what the claim is supposed to
be for better or worse
that no moral realist no moral realist
view
could have that effect so so so the view
is that like moral realism
is in a sense mixing up two issues one
issue is like
reality and independence of some truths
that i think is pretty cheap
another issue is deliberation and action
that issue cannot be kind of like
packed in to the the objects out there
because we can always ask ourselves
whether to consult those objects or
other objects and that can't be another
factual claim on pain of regress
so so so it's not that i think like
there is some other view one could have
that it's just way way out there and i
don't believe it according to which
moral facts tell us what to do
it's that i think they can't tell us
what to do and the argument's supposed
to show
show as much on the other hand if all
you're concerned with is are there
truths out there
um that are independent of human minds
and conventions
about what we ought to do well i think
yeah that's that's pretty cheap
actually that's not hard to establish
this must be
very frustrating for the traditional
moral realists who i think not only
believe in moral realism but they think
that they know what the right truths are
and you're sort of granting them moral
realism and saying but it means nothing
for when we actually get out there and
need to sw flip the switch on the
trolley
that's exactly right it's like analogous
to the view that look maybe there's a
god maybe there's not
in fact maybe there's a trivial argument
for the existence of god though i don't
think so in this case but suppose there
were
uh but still who cares who cares what
god thinks
it would be like the kind of view yeah
is there any uh practical implication
for the question of what we
what we are to do i mean at some point
we still need to answer that question
right absolutely
so so it's this is not the view
that um you know everybody should start
lighting cats on fire
um because there's no there's no there's
no answer to the question of whether to
light cats on fire or not
by the way that example's from gilbert
harmon's famous discussion i haven't
been thinking about
lighting cats on fire um uh so um
the the the claim is that all the action
is had at what you might call the
non-cognitive level
there's there's a whole nother sort of
um there's a whole nother
uh uh domain of deliberation
it's the final deliberation we have to
do before action
and it has nothing to do with facts and
this kind of deliberation has in fact
been investigated in some at some length
by so
for example uh alan gibbert in thinking
how to live
and um you know his framework deals with
things called
hyper plans which are these kind of like
um
idealized he takes the question of what
to do to
be basically the question of what hyper
plan to adopt which is kind of like an
idealized plan
um yeah so so that question all remains
the key point
is none of those questions and the way
to resolve them have anything to do with
what facts there are
in the world whether moral or non-moral
yeah they have nothing i mean
of course just to be clear they have to
do with what descriptive like whether
something makes people happy or sad or
whether it contributes to suffering or
not obviously that is relevant
but but once you've settled all the
descriptive facts
there's no further facts that have
anything to do with the question
we need to resolve i think that we've
earned uh
the right to kick back for the last
question here and
take a big picture of you let me because
one of the points you make
uh i forget whether it's just in
discussion or in the book
but there aren't that many people
writing books about morality in
mathematics which is
in some sense a shame because the goal
of philosophy
is to be sort of as broad in scope and
fundamental
as possible and yet we've
hyper-specialized right
uh you know how do you think about uh
i mean you you've given us a worked
example of an
engagement between two usually distinct
areas of philosophy i mean is there hope
uh for more of that or do we need to be
more
active in bringing it about or is it
always just going to be something a few
kooky individualists uh
choose to look at you know i mean like i
wish i had some
super useful practical advice for how to
to make this happen i mean the the
problem's nobody's fault it's just like
i i assume the same is true in physics
but
you can let me know if i'm wrong i mean
you know as
the years have gone on the discussions
have become more involved and
sophisticated
and it's you know it's it's um
it it's hard to stay on top of a lot of
different literature
so you really have to make an effort and
you really have to be looking for
connections
but i do think that for example as
someone who's real interested in both
ethics and philosophy of math and you
know goes to conferences and of both
kinds and stuff i do think that it's
it's striking how often the same kinds
of issues arise
and there's a bit of reinventing the
wheel across
different areas of philosophy in my
experience and so it does suggest to me
that it would be useful every
now and again to have like kind of
cross-disciplinary conferences where
it's not expected that you know the
other area but
the people in each part are trying to
kind of explain to the others where
they're coming from
and you realize points of overlap and
points where one conversation could
inform the other
and you know if nothing else i hope the
book shows that that's not like
just a academic exercise
it's obviously an academic exercise but
it's not just an academic exercise
uh because there you know in my view
like you know i've been thinking about
ethics and philosophy of math for a
while
and sort of what view to take of each
and the comparison is what allowed me to
arrive at positive views of each
i don't think i would have arrived at
the view that i ended up arriving at
about ethics or
philosophy of math without thinking
about the other so it's it really
can it seem to me enrich you know
just the the research one was already
doing in their field
but but i i don't have any magic pill
for how to how to make it easier because
you know
just like any academic field the
literature has exploded and it's got
more and more technical and all that
stuff
and and yeah i wish that
i wish i knew how to avoid um
you know the work required i guess to
really dig in i think you know one
very simple thing that i can say is that
uh
it's absolutely going to be necessary to
have individuals who are willing to put
in the work
in multiple areas um but at the same
time
we should not forget the value of not
just doing the hyper-specialized
technical work which is
intrinsically valuable and i'm all in
favor of it it's a good thing but
also packaging the best and most
important parts of it
in a more widely accessible form um
i mean in some form that's what we're
doing here on the podcast
right uh we're trying to get uh very
different areas in ways that are very
broadly
accessible and then and then at least if
you want your if you want to make
original contributions to the field
you're going to have to dig in more
deeply but
at least you might be able to have some
informed judgment about whether or not
it's worth your time
to dig in more deeply to one field or
another totally absolutely no like i
mean i
i you know i really consider you kind of
a savant at this
and and i think that yeah the um
that i i should have said something
about that it's i'm not so great at that
myself
as maybe this podcast reveals but but i
think that's enormously important and
it's even important you know i mean so
for example
uh last example i'll use you know um in
uh
in set theory you know set theory is a
relatively
fringe area of philosophy sorry of math
of pure math
and there's this very important kind of
development that happened a long time
ago in the 60s
the development of forcing which is a
certain kind of independence proof
technique
and you know at some point along the way
people started saying you know we have
an open what's called an open
what they call an open exposition
problem we need to figure out how to
package forcing in a way that other
mathematicians can understand what
forcing is and that is a genuine problem
as much as kind of the question of
whether the twin primes conjecture is
true
how do you how do you put it and i i
completely agree with you from the
purpose of you know the general
scientific enterprise
trying to figure out how the world is
that has to be part of it
and it's as as important as just the on
the ground work that you get trained to
do in grad school
so i'm 100 agreement and i love that you
are contributing
well as at the end of so many podcasts
uh the final thought is
oh good there's plenty more work to do
uh
never going to run out of good work to
do so justin clark doan thanks so much
for being on the bindscape podcast this
was great
thanks so much for having me thanks
[Music]
you